the sandman is the reason that i write
comic books i picked up the volumes for
the first time when i was in high school
and they completely changed what i
thought comic books could be the sandman
universe nightmare country tells the
story of the corinthian the most
terrifying nightmare in the dreaming and
probably my favorite character from the
original sandman comics
he was created to be a dark mirror to be
held against humanity and i wanted to
create a story where i could hold him
against the world that we live in today
when you want to write a horror story
one of the most important things is
finding an artist who can capture the
full breadth of human emotion because
horror is defined by how people react to
things
one of my favorite things that we're
going to be able to do is feature a
whole host of incredible horror artists
who are going to tell stories featuring
the corinthians these shorts are going
to run as part of the story and they are
very crucial to the larger narrative
we're building this book is going to be
beautiful
[Music]
you